band di ragazzi pervenute questo
nuovissimo video di rocket league con lo
stesso ne vediamo se riusciamo a fare
oggi 22 allora vediamo se riesco ad
aprire un ritrovamento a produrre trova
menti quando l'ho detto e lo scorso
video prima colorarono normale lo trovo
uno schifo quindi a prescindere non me
ne frega niente e adesso ritrovamento
molto raro ragazzi invece no sempre il
tifo o mar audero trovato il mar auder
che una macchina può sempre fortunato
comunque spiega incredibili ho veramente
sempre l'ultimo certi poi puoi trovare o
uno schifo o medio alto se me lo schifo
baceranno una vocale dei nomi per caso
sono due nomi una vocale solo che
pertanto locale da vocali invenio casinò
e vai
ed è subito gol dello stesso rialzino
del favi anzi no orientami aperto che è
questa una finta rapina anthai via
stampato perché si è spaventato dalla
vita all'inizio onesto hai visto e non
tutti dei tasselli come sulla gara si
sia da 6 l
è veramente tante mi vede tutto
bravissimo va bene scrive schiattare via
vinte tutta franchezza mi dissocio da
era ma è giusto perché un esempio va
bene mamma mia che gol parlare io non ci
sono state né il turbo
niente niente ci ho parlato io di
retromarcia ma non c'è stato belle
eccoci però vero toccato dai palazzoni
lazio è sempre loro non si sa come
sempre loro sempre loro e loro è rimasto
niente script del gioco questo ok che
questo è tutto previsto ancora è tutto
parte di uno schema più grande che è in
grado sono vede infatti come vedi sono
già qui a pagare l'avanti ma lo sapevi
ma lo sapevi perché io non voglio
avanzare per trovare poi questo
ovviamente per i segni nolo mancata ma
loro se lo aspettavano il tocco è tutto
un segno si sia come gli scacchi
comunque tutto previsto
guarda guarda allora non capiscono più
nulla adesso si è così e poi arrivare
che non si aspettano da rivera
ti prego facciamo gol così lo previsto
perché credi normale
noi prevediamo tutto si si dà tutto in
mezzo e ho previsto quello che ne sono
stati così alto come tirare per segnare
tutto brady ragazzi era tutto calcolato
se sì tutto calcolato dal minuto 4 sì
abbiamo gol di vantaggio ne manca uno
adesso rimane la non arrivare la pole è
vero te l'ho detto per fartelo credere
per ritardi e per cui segnare adesso
invece palo ma lo previsto il palo devo
fare i know you tube quelli del meteo ha
capito niente
il 100 per cento a cure e felipe abbiamo
fatto esporre loro adesso sono fuori
posizione e quindi sono fregati a fare
questo dribbling ma molto bello che i
passi futuri avere fortissimi così con
l'alfiere puoi dargli scacco proprio che
io marte tiro la pago però poi alla loro
corretta non capiscono alla rottura
rimette così
evvai vado anch'io a rubarglielo è va
bene giusto giusto a sette secondi alla
finestra ma tanto perfetto tutto
calcolato
dalle 14 esatto per fare mediche si
evince calcolando nelle partite siamo
dei calcolate le calcolatrici è
importante studiare
io sono una calcolatrice scientifica
cell in non capisco neanche io come
cazzo sono fatto andiamo con la prossima
ragazzi ok ragazzi siamo cosa no vabbè
wings of kfc le alette di pollo nel kfc
e noi c'è un mito 36 quindi soft kfc è
incredibile come si vede che è di sicuro
ne decano lui penserebbe tirare aspetta
puoi tirare ancora lo stesso
mamma mia parte pochezze prego subito
noi incredibile poi non segniamo per sei
ora non dettaglio comunque il tuo il tuo
emblema no quello di fianco al problema
vi ricordo un sacco cyber drago di è
vero è uguale mamma mia
era fortissimo se per droga poi
diventavano tre serie a drago finale
occhio di una piega che sei da solo poi
segnare va bene
ingrosso ingrosso guardalo grosse
calcolato per wings of kfc guardano ma
perché ovviamente vince rimpallo vince
sempre quello che lo do per scontato ma
il già quando sai che sto andando io
perché tanto non vincere un major iv ha
previsto una roba assurda colpo di coda
tendente a tipo che si lascia via gol
bello sopra sarda è stato bravo un
proprio bravo sono rimasto lì per per la
spondina il corpo di colpo di coda
aumenta la leaf e diminuisce la difesa
avversaria
è vero non si sanno questa roba quindi è
normale bisogna spiegarlo però se
landini ci portiamo subito il vantaggio
21 verrà precisa precisa per far loro un
questa bella però no maledizione quanto
notturno piuttosto ampia questa palla
bravo ti aspetta siamo andati in due
parole fan pato però cerchio wings of
kfc che vola dovrà arrivare un
bravissimo bravo c'è ancora niente
perché non avevo più duratura ti sei
messo
ma perché mezza volta non entra una cosa
così abbiamo continuato a prendere
traverse pali righe tira la palla gran
gol
me ne frega e non me ne frega niente di
come finisce la metto la gente deve
sapere non può essere e rimanere
impunita questa cosa
epic games peak a the fix a te sto gioco
per cortesia fissatelo non e guarda
guarda guarda come vincolo guarda guarda
come vincono guarda io mi dissocio da
questo gioco mi dissocio
ecco ecco perché in alcuni pirati ladina
di latina tivano di qualche ragazzino
barbetta faccio qualcosa non so cosa
faccio cani gioco giorno forte tremezzo
porterà in mezzo dobbiamo documentare
tutto questo scempio che incredibile
guarda prego ha fatto bene questo non
l'avesse segnano lo vedo niente sto io
vedo niente c'era il fumo c'era il fumo
toglietelo su fumo non vedevo nulla non
potevo toccarla perché entrava ti giuro
guarda avevo il fumo davanti non vedevo
nulla
te lo giuro dalla mia visione non vedevo
nulla solo bomporto pettinari e
bellissimo bellissimo quasi si giocava
quando gli avversari non hanno più
capito nulla loro che non te lo te lo
giuro che non vedevo niente vanno a ma
si capiva
eccola qui bellissimo bellissimo grazie
del bar fratello non so come
ringraziarti non reggo letto 45 secondi
niente nella vita prego ti prego ti
prego no no no no no la pregiato è
finita è finita è finita
il cross così però ci proviamo lentezza
io non esistono scuse ci proviamo cerci
prima volta tanto la metto perché da
documentare ragazzi cioè voi che dovete
capire perché noi perdiamo le partite
per questo motivo non possiamo prendere
62 pali questo video domanda è preso
perfetta ma andiamo alla epic games
subito siamo ragazzi c'è qualcosa che
dovrete fixare guarda ecco bellissimo
bravo 3 gol triplo 7 per lo step di
punteggio gravissimo piena latina latina
la maledizione per avere navarro lui si
è scomposto tantissimo non può non esita
o ragazze ma cosa ma cosa ma cosa ma
dove
ma dai ma dove ma cosa ha preso dal muro
ma ha fatto capire che sarebbe andata lì
è pazzesca sta roba
vai vai ancora credici attenzione noi
crediamo ci crediamo crediamo ci tirino
ad atti relativi alla però no perché
sono stata leggermente era il computer
che sia ha detto no anche lui no del
demonio che cacchio sia aperto sul
computer di la maledizione no no la
mettiamo questa per me ne frega niente
della cometa ragazzi dobbiamo
documentare anche ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto ringrazio stefano per aver
partecipato come sempre ci rivediamo
hanno proseguito belle ragazze
[Musica]